nous sommes avec laurence dongle
enseignante et chercheuse bonjour merci
d'être avec nous aux élections
présidentielles en octobre en côte
d'ivoire est la question du retour de
laurent gbagbo dans le pays et tout
coeur des audiences de ce jour est-ce
que selon vous son retour dans le pays
est envisageable
le retour du président laura bat laurent
gbagbo en côte d'ivoire plus
qu'envisageable à mon avis il serait
souhaitable qu'il reparte parce
qu'aujourd'hui la côte d'ivoire a besoin
de réconciliation
lorsque le président alassane ouattara
est arrivé au pouvoir en 2010 qu'il
avait fait de cette réconciliation une
priorité et je pense que là le retour de
laurent gbagbo du président laurent
gbagbo de charles blé goudé et des
autres exilés en côte d'ivoire c'est un
pas vers la réconciliation nous venons
de voir les images
le président gbagbo est attendu par une
partie de la population
on ne sait pas s'il est majoritaire ou
pas mais à partir du moment où cette
population a des attentes dont les voix
nombreux dans les meetings où on les
voit nombreux sur les réseaux sociaux à
réclamer son retour donc l'empêcher de
repartir c'est moi je pense continuer
d'entretenir le conflit et quand on se
rend compte qu'aujourd'hui en côte
d'ivoire on a un guillaume soro qui
était présent l'assemblée nationale n'y
a pas encore longtemps qu'elle était
premier ministre qui aussi est privé de
rentrer en côte d'ivoire tout ça
n'augure pas d'une véritable
réconciliation or aujourd'hui la côte
d'ivoire a tout à gagner à aller vers la
réconciliation l'afrique aussi à gagner
avec une côte d'ivoire apaisée une côte
d'ivoire qui fonctionne correctement qu'
une côte d'ivoire démocratique et ça
c'est primordial je pense pour les
ivoiriens pour l'afrique
alors on le rappelle laurent nago a donc
l'interdiction de quitter bruxelles où
il réside depuis son acquittement le 15
janvier 2019 les avocats de côte
d'ivoire se sont exprimés selon eux son
retour en côte d'ivoire serait un
facteur de graves désordres celle
inverse de ce que vous nous disiez à
l'instant oui je pleure pour leur
posture n'est pas compréhensible
à mon avis elle n'est pas compréhensible
dans la mesure où laurent gbagbo a été
acquitté il a été acquitté de toutes les
charges qui pesait contre lui quand même
après sept ans de procédure
après 82 témoin passé à la barre
après trois ans de procès le procès
commence en janvier 2016 à janvier 2019
il est déclaré à quitter carrément quand
on regarde la pelle que madame fatou
bensouda a interjeté
elle ne demande même pas qu'ils soient
reconnues coupables elles demandent que
le verdict soit changée de
l'acquittement en un non lieu
donc laurent gbagbo en réalité n'a rien
qui est retenu contre lui le non lieu
permettrait aux dossiers de rester
ouvert et de continuer à mener des
enquêtes ont sonné dans le procès
d'intention et ça ce n'est pas une très
très bonne chose parce que si on reste
sur les faits laurent gbagbo a été
acquitté et ils méritent de rentrer chez
lui et son avocat justement dénonce une
décision arbitraire qui si elles étaient
maintenues rendrait la cour pénale
internationale responsable d'ingérence
dans la vie politique ivoirienne c'est
votre sentiment aussi la cour pénale
internationale est là pour traiter des
questions juridiques les questions
juridiques on a porté plainte en emmener
monsieur le président laurent gbagbo à
la halla halla halla complète à
l'international parce qu'on lui
reprochait des crimes contre l'humanité
et il avait des charges qui étaient
retenues contre lui il a été acquitté de
toutes ces charges donc je pose que le
travail de la cpi s'arrête là une fois
qu'un individu qu'une personne qui a été
jugé et acquitté la suite il est libre
de faire de sa vie ce qu'il veut il est
un citoyen ivoirien
il doit continuer de jouir de ses droits
pleinement vu qu'il a été acquitté donc
le fait qu'on veuille le retenir
loin de la côte d'ivoire en cette année
électorale vous savez le fait que tout
ça coïncide avec un calendrier électoral
c'est pas très rassurant sans vouloir
repenser au complot mais on a le
sentiment qu'on se garde laurent gbagbo
hors de la côte d'ivoire on maintient un
appel dont le procès sera fait après
octobre donc après les élections
donc la concomitance de cette retenue de
le président laurent gbagbo et de chats
blé goudé hors de la côte d'ivoire avec
le plus calendrier électoral onpe
diverses anoblir pas ça ne rassure pas
en tout cas
et quand on sait que cette crise
ivoirienne provient d'une élection
présidentielle antécédents les ivoiriens
ont besoin aujourd'hui d'être rassurés
et donc il faut poser des actes qui
montrent que la prochaine élection sera
libre transparente qu'elle ne souffrira
d'aucune
contestation et ce sera un signe fort
pour la réconciliation ivoirienne que
cette élection se déroule dans les
règles de l'art d'une élection
démocratique avec la participation de
tous les ivoiriens en âge de voter
de tous les ivoiriens libres justes en
de leurs droits civils et laurent gbagbo
fait partie du dernier mot laurent
gbagbo et charles blé goudé ont été
jugés par ont été condamnés condamné
pardon par contumace par la justice
ivoirienne très concrètement que peut-il
se passer pour eux s'ils rentrent en
côte d'ivoire alors comment comprendre
que le gouvernement ivoirien qui avait
jugé à l'époque qui n'était pas en
mesure qui avait jugé vu qu'il n'était
pas en mesure de traiter cette affaire a
envoyé le président laurent gbagbo est
charles blé goudé à la haine parce
qu'ils se sont sentis incapable de les
juger
une fois à la haine ils ont été
acquittés comment se fait-il qu'en côte
d'ivoire tout d'un coup on les juge
après qu'ils aient été acquittés alain
et on les juge par contumace alors
qu'ils n'ont pas refusé de comparaître
dont je dis tout ça me rassure pas le
président alassane ouattara il a fait
deux mandats
aujourd'hui il est il est au pouvoir il
a la possibilité je pense que ce serait
à son avantage de laisser une côte
d'ivoire un paisible côte d'ivoire
prospère et je pense que le retour du
président laurent gbagbo de charles blé
goudé de tous les exilés
ce serait un gage fort de cette
réconciliation avec bien sûr un accueil
une réception par le président alassane
ouattara
ça donnera ainsi une très très forte la
réconciliation que tu vois merci
beaucoup pour votre regard laurence donc
enseignante et chercheuse le rêve